(audience applauding)
That's right.
It's time for Drew's News
and if news were bagels,
we try to be the everything.
(Ross laughing)
And, with me at the desk is my toasty little sesame seed,
Ross Mathews!
Hi!
Hi, everybody!
(audience applauding)
Hi, Drew.
You are a delightful topping, aren't you?
(Ross laughing)
If I had a nickel, thank you.
All right, we're gonna kick it off with Broadway!
'Cause we've got the news we've all been waiting for.
Forbes reports that smash hits "Hamilton," "Wicked,"
and "The Lion King," are all officially reopening
on September 14th.
Ah, my God.
And right behind them-
Yes!
Right behind these icons is also some super fresh,
new, exciting shows.
Six very exciting.
This is a huge play about Henry VIII's wives.
Oh, wow!
Yeah.
And this is like the "It" show.
And it's finally coming to New York on September 17th.
There's so much buzz about it.
It's bananas.
You've got one to tell us about.
Well, "Mrs. Doubtfire," hello!
"Drive-by fruiting!"
(audience laughing)
It's in previews, on October 21st.
We can't wait to see that.
"The Music Man," with Hugh Jackman
will finally start previews.
And Sutton Foster.
Yes!
Side note, I was at dinner the other night,
and Hugh Jackman was right over there.
(Drew gasps)
I know.
Oh, my God, a Hugh Jackman sighting?
That's a good one, right?
Yeah, I was so nervous.
There's also "Beetlejuice,"
"Dear Evan Hansen" is coming back.
Well, it's so exciting, because, you know,
Broadway is so important
and it's just been, the city has just felt so empty
without it, without the energy of it.
I think we need more than ever, right, to be entertained.
A showstopping number sounds good right about now.
So, if you've never been to a Broadway show,
I hope one day you get to experience it.
I remember the first time just being, like,
that I saw, I couldn't believe what I was seeing.
But there's great entertainment all around this country.
So, if it's coming back on Broadway,
hopefully shows are coming back where you are as well
and just go out and support them.
And there's such a variety.
It's not just musicals now.
You have kind of every single box to check
as far as what you could be looking for on Broadway.
So your tastes will be met, which I love.
Totally.
And it just feels like, it's just an incredible thing
to see these reopenings after such a challenging year.
But, you know, there may be one silver lining of 2020.
Many people say, this year, made them into a better person.
Good News Network reports, a new survey of 2000 Americans
found that 64% said the struggles of 2020
made them actually more aware of others.
41% said that they actually helped a stranger
across the street.
31% walked a neighbor's dog just to help.
And listen to this stat,
a whopping 87% said that they donated money
from their paychecks,
even though three out of five people
experienced financial hardships.
And this just goes to prove the power of humanity.
Don't you think?
There's this sign I saw recently
and I can't get it out of my head
and I really wanna share it with everybody.
Here it is.
It comes from an Instagram account I really love,
El Arroyo restaurant in Austin, Texas.
Here's the sign,
"Ever notice that 2021 is pronounced 2020 won?"
Yeah.
I do believe with all the catastrophe that happened,
that we can't even begin to be sensitive enough.
But to see on the other side of that coin,
that the polarity is that people have stepped up
in ways that they simply were not doing before?
That to me makes me feel like 2021
in behavior, optimism, possibilities,
new ways for us to live and treat each other.
And, I just love this sign
and it's gonna stay with me for a very long time.
By the way, it's also a great Instagram account to follow
because they do everything from like super profound
to just straight out funny.
"Why am I the only naked person
at this gender reveal party?"
(Ross laughing)
"Do people who run marathons know they don't have to?"
That's funny.
"I don't have my ducks in a row,
I have squirrels and they're at a rave."
(Ross giggling)
They're just, it's a funny company
and I just, I love the account.
So, you should follow them.
Well, guess what, Drew?
What?
The people at El Arroyo
are sending the love right back to you.
What?!
Yes, they made a sign for you!
(Drew gasps)
"Drew unto others as you would have them Drew to you."
(audience applauding and cheering)
Surprise!
(Ross laughing)
You made it, big time.
Oh, my God.
This is such a cool surprise.
I love you, El Arroyo.
I've been following you all year
and you've brought so much joy into my life.
And I can't believe I'm on your sign
and by the way, wow!
'Cause you guys know humor, but this is like funny
and cute and, like, heartfelt.
Oh, gosh, thank you.
Oh, my God.
I'm on the El Arroyo sign!
(Ross laughing)
I knew you'd love that, Drew.
And by the way, yeah.
Do unto others the way you want done to yourself.
And I think that's the good news about 2020
as we started acting, perceiving,
and behaving differently.
And we started fighting for each other
instead of with each other.
Yeah, and I think we really realized
when we couldn't have each other, that we need each other.
So congrats on your big sign.
And I love that for you.
(Drew gasps)
I am literally, I wanna get that framed.
And the 2020, I can't believe it.
Thank you, guys, so much.
That is, like, a huge, huge honor for me.
Yeah, well, I'm happy for you.
Hey, and, next,
we've got some new dating advice from Refinery29.
They talked to a relationship coach,
who says that while it's important to notice,
this is interesting.
You know, you always say,
"Look for red flags in the relationship?"
Well, they say it's also important to look for green flags.
'Cause sometimes the red flag trigger,
it might be a little too itchy,
our little trigger finger, right?
I actually had a friend who was just recently dating,
was like, "Oh, I'm just waiting for the red flag.
and waiting for the thing
that's gonna show me that he's crazy."
And I thought that putting that out there
is the worst thing you could do.
I agree.
'Cause you're like collecting evidence of,
"How are you gonna do me wrong?"
Well also, like, you're just a self-fulfilling prophecy
at that point.
Totally.
So refocusing red flags
and looking for green flags.
Why is it working?
Why is this person good?
What do they bring to the table that is beneficial?
Well, my best friend, Nan, the almighty Nan,
she used to have me do a lot of pros and cons lists.
Oh, yeah?
And I think that a pros and cons list
is a really important thing to do
for yourself and for your life.
And it falls totally in line with the green flags
and we need to recognize the good in people
instead of waiting for the other shoe to drop
or talking about the red flags.
'Cause I feel like we're so focusing
on the red flags more than the green.
Tots, but, yes,
and don't ignore the red flags either.
All right, because people are crazy out there.
I'm just saying it's important to look at the good stuff,
but-
Well, that's why you make the pros and cons list
because you're not ignoring the red flags,
but you might see that there is more good than bad.
And, by the way, you're not perfect either.
Oh, okay.
It's true.
Truth bomb.
I can't help it.
I just think people have crazy expectations
when it comes to others
and they don't look at themselves often enough either.
We're all a little shuggie.
(Ross laughing)
And, we need to keep our own side of the street clean.
I think relationships should also be easy and fun
and give you a ton of pleasure.
But, I think looking at that balance of the red
and green flags will help you see where the imbalance lies.
What does shuggie mean?
Shuggie is like Yiddish.
It means crazy.
Okay, good to know.
And we are all a little crazy.
(Ross laughing)
Some of us more than others.
It comes from Meshugana.
Oh, there you go.
Thank you for that.
So shuggie is like that kind of, it's Yiddish with flair.
(Ross giggling)
(audience laughing)
Thank you.
Okay, and finally,
(Drew claps hands)
this is a very important story.
I really find that it's actionable
and really important information.
And I didn't know it.
So, I wanna share it with everybody else.
You may already know this,
but if you don't, this is important.
Vaccines just got even easier.
The Wall Street Journal reports that Uber and Lyft
are offering free rides to vaccine sites until July 4th.
They've teamed up with the White House
as part of President Biden's goal
to make sure that 70% of the population
has at least one shot by that holiday.
And Uber and Lyft hope this also helps
bring more people back to work and their apps
and it's full circle, really helping everyone.
And in other news, vaccines also had been reported
that the CDC has approved the Pfizer vaccine
for children ages 12 to 15
and they're gonna start out the rollout immediately.
So that summer camps, summer schools, summer hangs.
All of that stuff can start to get back to normal
or our new normal sooner than later.
Thank you.
So, important information to know.
(audience applauding)
Very important.
Thanks Uber and Lyft.
Five stars.
(theme music playing)